>> Tucker Carlson: GOOD
EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT, IN THE
SUMMER OF 2020 MOBS OF JOE
MUNDEN BOATERS DESTROYED FOR
PARTS OF MINNEAPOLIS.
THEY MURDERED PEOPLE, BUT THEY
DID THIS, WE INFORMED THAT THE
TIME IN THE NAME OF SOMETHING
CALLED RACIAL JUSTICE.
BUT THEN WE SAW THE SUM OF THE
MOB TURNED OUT TO BE FOR THE
RICH WHITE KIDS.
BUT, THEY SAID THAT THEY WERE
WRITING ON BEHALF OF SO-CALLED
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
THEY WERE WORKING FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE AND BECAUSE OF THAT THEY
CANNOT BE PUNISHED FOR WHAT THEY
DID.
NOR BY THE WAY WITH A RECORD
REQUIRED TO WEAR COVID NOT
AFFECT THE REST OF US.
THAT'S A WHOLE INTERMISSION IS
WISE.
THEY WERE EXEMPT FROM THE NORMAL
LOSS OF CIVILIZATION.
KAMALA HARRIS RAISE MONEY FOR
THAT, BUT THEY WERE
MISSIONARIES.
YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER THAT?
BUT DO YOU RECALL WHAT HAPPENED
NEXT IN MINNEAPOLIS?
THAT IS THE PART OF THE STORY
THE MEDIA HAD NO INTEREST IN
COVERING.
THEN THEY NEVER DO, THE IRON LAW
OF LIBERAL SOCIAL ACTIVISM IS
THAT YOU NEVER REVISIT THE
SCENES OF YOUR MORAL VICTORIES.
YOU GIVE A SPEECH DECLARING
YOURSELF A GOOD PERSON THEY GO
HOME.
HE DID NOT RETURN TO SELMA,
STILETTO, OR FERGUSON, MISSOURI,
TO SEE HOW PEOPLE ARE DOING
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ABOUT THOSE
PEOPLE IT IS ABOUT YOU AND YOUR
NEWLY ENHANCED MORAL AUTHORITY
WHICH IS INSTANTLY CONVERTIBLE
TO POLITICAL POWER AND CASH.
AS FOR BARACK OBAMA, BUT IN THE
SPRING OF 2021 WILL REPORTED
DECIDE TO BREAK THE PROTOCOL AND
GO BACK TO MINNEAPOLIS A YEAR
LATER.
HE WANTED TO SEE WHAT RACIAL
JUSTICE IS DONE FOR THE CITY.
HIS NAME WAS MICHAEL TRACY AND
AS YOU IMAGINE HE -- ONE NIGHT
WHILE HE WAS IN MINNEAPOLIS A A
MAN WALKED INTO A SOMALI OWN
CONVENIENCE STORE AND MURDERED
THE CLERK.
TRACY WANTED TO KNOW WHY THAT
HAPPENED AND WE STARTED TO
INTERVIEW PEOPLE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, ONE OF THEM TOLD
HIM THIS "AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
HUNTING SOMALIS IN MINNEAPOLIS
WHY IS THAT?"
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY
ARE GETTING SPECIAL FAVORS FROM
THE GOVERNMENT.
ARE YOU SURPRISED TO HEAR THAT?
YOU SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISED.
BECAUSE WHEN GOVERNMENT CREATES
A SPOILS SYSTEM BASED ON RACE
AND ETHNICITY IN OUR GOVERNMENT
CERTAINLY HAS DONE THAT,
DIVISION AND VIOLENCE ARE THE
INEVITABLE OUTCOMES.
THAT IS TRUE ALWAYS AND
EVERYWHERE.
THE FACTS NEVER CHANGE.
AND LIBERALS FOR MANY DEFICITS
USED TO PROTECT AND UNDERSTAND
THAT.
THAT'S WHY THEY OPPOSE JIM CROW,
AND THE NUREMBERG LAWS.
BUT AT SOME POINT, TO BE
INTERESTING TO KNOW WHEN AND WHY
LIBERALS ENTHUSIASTICALLY
EMBRACE THE RACIAL SPOILS
SYSTEM.
THEY WANT CLAIMS TO HATE.
THIS IS UNFOLDING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHAT IS ESPECIALLY
PREVALENT IN PLACES LIBERALS
CONTROL.
THE MORE POWER LIBERALS HAVE,
THE MORE SWEEPING AND LIT -- THE
SYSTEM THEY CREATE.
IN CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE UP TO
PAR AND THAT'S WHY THE
GOVERNMENT OF SAN FRANCISCO IS
JUST ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WILL
SEND YOU MONEY IF YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT SKIN COLOR.
>> MORE CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
THE BAY AREA ARE STUNNING
GUARANTEED INCOME PROGRAMS FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
SILICON VALLEY AND GUARANTEED A
PILOT PROGRAM SAYING THAT IT
WILL TARGET PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
UNDOCUMENTED MS STATUS FAMILIES
AND WOMEN LEAD HOUSEHOLDS.
150 FAMILIES WILL GET $1,000 A
MONTH FOR TWO YEARS WITH NO
STRINGS ATTACHED.
>> THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY, IF YOU ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE PERSON IN THE
COMMUNITY YOU GET A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER MONTH.
BUT THAT SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE HOMELESS GUY OLD
BEING IN THE PARK ON SITE NO IF
HE'S WHITE.
IF HE'S WHITE PECAN DIED BECAUSE
IF HE IS RIGHT EVEN IF HE IS
DYING HE IS BY DEFINITION NOT
VULNERABLE.
KIND OF FUNNY AND NOW HAS MANY
PROGRAM LIKE THIS AND THIS STATE
IS NOW PROPOSED A REPARATIONS
PROGRAM FOR THE DESCENDANTS OF.
IT SEEMS SIMPLE BUT THERE'S A
PROBLEM WITH IT HOW YOU KNOW WHO
QUALIFIES FOR REPARATIONS?
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME IT'S BEEN
OVER A HUNDRED AND 50 YEARS IN
SLAVERY AND AMERICANS HAVE MADE
A LOT OF BABY SINCE THEN.
MANY OF THEM ARE INTERRACIAL.
SO AT THIS POINT, THERE ARE
PLENTY OF WHITE PEOPLE IN
AMERICA WHO ARE DESCENDED FROM,
AND THERE ARE PLENTY PEOPLE AT
AMERICAN FUNDS DESCENDED FROM
SLAVE OWNERS.
THAT'S JUST TRUE.
SO HOW DO YOU NOBLE QUALIFIES
FOR GOVERNMENT REPARATION?
THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY TO FIND
OUT, THAT IS OLD-FASHIONED RACE
SCIENCE.
NOT THE RACE SCIENCE.
SO THE STATE WILL HAVE TO
CERTIFIED THAT PURITY OF ITS
CITIZENS IN ORDER TO SEND THE
MONEY.
THAT'S CAN HAVE TO HAPPEN.
DO WE REALLY WANT TO GO THERE?
TWO OF YOU WHO WANT TO DO THAT?
AMAZINGLY LIBERALS REALLY DO.
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
JUSTIFIED ITS ELECTIONS DIRECTOR
BECAUSE HE IS WHITE.
WHEN NOT GUESSING AT THAT, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ELECTION
COMMISSION CRISCO DAN AKIN FROM
FROM THAT WAS THE REASONING YOU
WERE QUOTING, A DECISION HE
SAID, TO THE MAN WHO WAS FIRED
AS AN APPROPRIATE PERFORMANCE
BUT AFTER 20 YEARS WE WANTED TO
TAKE ACTION ON THIS IN THE
RACIALLY EQUITY PLAN AND GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE
FOR LEADERSHIP POSITION.
>> : FOR SKIN COLOR.
I WEIGH AGAINST THAT IF WE HAVE
A CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT TO STOP
THAT AND BY THE WAY THIS
SPECIFIC CASE THE GUY WHO GOT
FIRED SINGLE-HANDEDLY AND DID
WIDESPREAD CORRUPTION AND
INCOMPETENCE IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
ELECTION.
HE HAD THE JOB FOR TWO DECADES,
THEY SAID BELLA BOXES COMING UP
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AND
THAT WAS FRAUD BUT HE STOPPED
IT.
BUT HIS SKIN COLOR WAS THE
PROBLEM.
THE SKATE SHADE OF HIS SKIN WAS
MORE OFFENSIVE TO LIBERALS IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND FRAUDULENT
ELECTIONS.
NOW THERE WAS AN OUTCRY IN THIS
AND HE ULTIMATELY GOT HIS JOB
BACK, BUT THE GOVERNMENT, NOT
JUST THE PEOPLE STILL ENDORSES
THE IDEA OF -- THEY LAUNCHED A
SEPARATE GOVERNMENT -- FOR
PREGNANT BLACK WOMAN.
IT PAYS UP TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH.
IN THAT PROGRAM GOT MORE THAN
5 MILLION MORE IN STATE FUNDING
SO IT'S EXPANDING, NOT TO
LOS ANGELES AND IN OTHER AREAS.
IN THE LEFT-WING GROUP EXPECTING
JUSTICE JEALOUS, PUT TOGETHER
THIS PROMO FOR THE PROGRAM
WATCH.
>> MANY PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
THIS BUT HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO
MANY BLACK WOMEN HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE RISK OF
MORTALITY, AND INFANT MORTALITY
AND PREGNANT COMPETENT PATIENCE
AND OTHER PEOPLE, AND THEY DON'T
REALIZE THAT THIS IS REALLY DUE
TO RACISM.
BOTH CHUCK WILL RACISM, AND THE
RACISM THAT BRINGING PEOPLE AND
OTHER PEOPLE EXPERIENCE WHEN
THEY'RE INTERACTING WITH
POSITION AND OTHER MEDICAL
PROVIDERS.
>> SO THAT IS EVERY WORD OF IT
ERASES PLY, THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT THIS EXISTS IN THIS COUNTRY
I GUESS THE COMMUNITY SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT OR NONE WHATSOEVER
THAT CAUSES HIGHER INFANT
MORTALITY.
THERE'S NO SIGNS WHATSOEVER THAT
JUST ERASES LIE, BUT MORE TO THE
POINT NOBODY SAYS BIRTHING
PEOPLE SHOULD EVER BE IN CHARGE
OF HANDING OUT MONEY TO MOTHERS.
MUCH LESS TAXPAYERS MONEY.
BUT OF COURSE THAT IS HAPPENING,
THAT'S ALL YOU THAT THIS IS A
GRAFT.
THIS IS A SCAM.
DECIDE TO SHUT MY NAME FROM
PEOPLE WHO MAKE IT, TO PEOPLE
WHO VOTE FOR THE RIGHT PARTY.
AND THAT'S WHY SHEILA JACKSON
RECENTLY DEMANDED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF REPARATIONS BECAUSE
THAT SHE SAID WOULD BE OF BUNCH
DELETE THAT ARE RELATED TO LOOK
OVER.
>> INFANT LATELY HARVARD
MEDICAL SCHOOL SUGGESTED THEY
REPARATIONS FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS COULD HAVE CUT
COVID-19 TRANSMISSIONS AND
INFECTION RATES BOTH AMONG BLACK
PEOPLE, AND THE POPULATION AT
LARGE.
>> Tucker Carlson: 'S SOUL,
SHE'S A CHARACTER TO MAKE FUN
OF, BUT IT WAS NOT JUST HER --
THAT WAS THE OFFICIAL PRIVATION
OF THE PREVAILING VIEW OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN 2020.
VOTE FOR US AND WE WILL GIVE
REPARATIONS BASED ON SKIN COLOR.
>> PROPOSING A BILL TO STUDY
ABSOLUTE REPARATION.
>> WHILE ELECTED PRESIDENT.
>> WOULD YOU SEND THAT THOUGH?
>> YES.
>> I FIRMLY SUPPORT
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKSON LEAVES
BILL TO CREATE A COMMISSION TO
STUDY REPARATIONS.
>> WOULD YOU SIGN THE BILL FOR
REPARATION?
>> YES I WOULD I WOULD SUPPORT
THAT.
>> THERE ARE THINGS WE NEED TO
DO IN THIS COUNTRY IN AND HAVE
HAD A LONG TIME COMING.
ONE OF THOSE IS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH REPARATIONS.
>> SO AGAIN, IT IS HARD TO
OVERSTATE -- IN ORDER FOR THAT
TO WORK IN PRACTICE, YOU HAVE TO
TAKE PEOPLE'S BLOOD AND WOULD
FIGURE OUT WHAT PERCENTAGE THEY
WERE OF ONE RACE OF THE OTHER.
MAYBE MEASURE THEIR HEADS.
YOU WILL WIND UP WITH -- WITH
RACIAL PURITY TEST.
AND NO DECENT PERSON WANTS TO
LIVE IN A COUNTRY WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A DEAD IN A
TERRIBLE IDEA.
AND IT WOULD OF COURSE PROMOTE
VIOLENCE AND DIVISION.
SO, THAT IS A NONSTARTER WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
BUT JOE BIDEN DECIDED THAT HE
WAS GOING TO GET AROUND THE
NATIONAL DEBATE ON REPARATIONS
SIMPLY BY JUST DOING IT.
DOING IT IN THE FARM BILL.
RIGHT AFTER HE TOOK OFFICE, HE
ALLOCATED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FARM MADE BASED ON RACE, JUST ON
RACE.
THE JUDGE THANKFULLY SHUT THAT
DOWN.
BUT THEY DIDN'T SLOW DOWN IN
THEIR EFFORTS TO CREATE A RACIAL
SPOILS SYSTEM.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT WHAT IT
DOES TO THE COUNTRY.
SO, HERE SUGGESTED THAT CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES BASED ON THEIR SKIN
COLOR DESERVE FASTER HURRICANE
RESPONSE.
SO THERE'S AN ENTIRE CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, A DIVISION
DESIGNED TO STOP THE GOVERNMENT
FROM REWARDING OR PUNISHING
PEOPLE AND THE BASIS OF SKIN
COLOR, I WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT BUT
THEY ARE DOING NOTHING.
OF COURSE THEY'RE ENCOURAGING IT
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
SO AS A RESULT CALIFORNIA HAS
LAUNCHED ANOTHER BASIC INCOME
PROGRAM.
THIS TIME FOR TRANS PEOPLE, I
WAS LOCKED IN A WORK HOW DO YOU
PROVE YOUR TRANCE?
AND ANYONE EVEN DEFINE WHAT THAT
MEANS NO.
BUT HERE IT IS THEY'RE BRAGGING
ABOUT HOW MUCH TAXPAYER MONDAY
TO GET PEOPLE FOR BEING TRANS.
>> EVERY SINGLE YEAR, THIS ONE
COMES FORWARD WITH
GROUNDBREAKING UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENT AND PEOPLE.
AND THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE,
SHE FOCUSES ON THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY, AND SHE TALKS ABOUT
SOME OF THE MOST UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME IN SAN FRANCISCO.
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENTS
DIRECTED AT UNHOUSED TRENDS
FOLKS.
>> THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
REALLY?
I'LL BE MEASURING VULNERABILITY?
WHEN THE VIEWER SUPPORTS AND
CELEBRATES YOUR EXISTENCE EVERY
SINGLE DAY WHEN EVERY
FASHIONABLE PERSON IN AMERICA
POST TRIP IS CU AND SOCIAL MEDIA
EVERY WEEK.
HOW VULNERABLE ARE YOU?
BUT LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
LET'S MEASURE THAT THE HOUSEHOLD
INCOME, IS THE HOUSEHOLD INCOME
OF THE AVERAGE TRANS PERSON IN
AMERICA HIRE A LAWYER IN THE
INDIAN RESERVATION?
IS A HIGHER OR LOWER THAN TO SAY
IN RURAL IOWA.
AND WHAT IS TRANSGENDER.
ON THE CURRENT APPLICATION IN
SAN FRANCISCO, THEY ARE 97
DIFFERENT GENDER OPTIONS
AVAILABLE.
19 SEXUAL ORIENTATION, AND THESE
ARE CRUDE AROMATIC, SAME GENDER
LOVING, AND SCOLIOSIS ACTION.
SO AT THIS POINT, PROBABLY NOT
GONNA GET CALIFORNIA BACK INTO
THE REALM OF FUNCTIONAL
INTERCHANGE.
-- AND HE PRESIDED OVER BY A
SMALL GROUP AND INCREDIBLY RICH
PEOPLE EVERY KNOW A PERSON OF
ALL COLORS WILL HAVE LAUGHED AND
MOVED TO FLORIDA PROBABLY IS NO
FIXING IT AT THIS POINT.
THE BIG CUT IN THE REDWOOD
FOREST AND SEND THEM FOR MONEY
AND YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THIS
IS GOING LOOK